welcome back hope you had a good long
weekend
so today's puzzle is I guess a classic
puzzle it's it's Sudoku I've never
actually successfully managed to
complete a pseudo Koopas all by myself
because I've they fall into two
categories for me either it's easy
they're easy and and I get bored and I
stop or they're too hard and I get lazy
and I stop but what I have done is write
a computer program that essentially
solves any pseudocode puzzle that is put
in front of it in in seconds maybe if
there exists puzzles for which it would
take minutes but I haven't discovered
such puzzles and what we're going to do
today is talk about Sudoku compare and
contrast the human way of solving Sudoku
puzzles against brute force way and then
try and integrate the two together you
know perhaps this is the closest we're
going to get to AI in this class where
we're going to try and marry an
exhaustive search method with some
smarts and back I think when we were
doing the N Queens puzzle one of you
asked a question about what the number
of possibilities were you know for an
eight Queens puzzle was at a trace to
eight and I said well no you can prune
the search by figuring out that
particular partial configurations that
correspond to perhaps two queens being
placed on the 8x8 board already
I does not correspond to a solution
because the two queens conflict with
each other and you can then shrink this
eight raise to 8 substantially so that's
exactly the methodology that we're going
to follow here in trying to take our
brute force solver which will work and
you know given enough time on arbitrary
Sudoku puzzles but
may not want to wait that long and we're
gonna take this strategy of pruning the
search to try and improve the solve
world and one last thing before I get
started on the rules of Sudoku I'm we're
going to have to have a way of measuring
performance just like we can measure a
trace to 8 or 4 raise to 4 or what have
you we want to have a way of measuring
outside of the particular machine that's
being used we could obviously measure
real time in terms of seconds but that's
not as precise I you want to measure
more precisely what the number of
combinations are and so we could
certainly instrument our code with
appropriate counters that will allow us
to measure this performance and so then
it won't matter if our code runs on a
fast machine or a slow machine if we can
compare it with another piece of code or
another variant of the code and say oh
this new variant is slower or the new
variant is faster according to this
metric all right so without further ado
let's dive into Sudoku how many of you
have never seen Sudoku never played
Sudoku all right so that's fine it's
only going to take me about 30 seconds
to explain what the rules of Sudoku are
and then we can dive into trying to at
least partially solve this puzzle
III do not want to completely solve the
puzzle because as I said you know I'm
it's either too simple or it's too hard
and I'd rather write computer programs
and so so the rules of Sudoku are simple
um so this is that classic Sudoku and
it's 9 by 9
there's many variants of Sudoku in fact
a couple of the exercises talk about two
variants diagonal Sudoku and odd-even
Sudoku I think there's probably odd
Sudokus as well that add even more
constraints to the basic constraints of
Sudoku that I'm going to write up here
and this is 9 by 9 Sudoku and the
numbers are 1 through 9
and the rules are simple each row has
all the numbers which means that no
numbers could be repeated because this
there's nine columns and nine rows so
there's nine numbers on each row each
column has all the numbers same thing so
there's nine rows and nine columns and
then each sector which is at three by
three grid and so that's why I have
these overhangs here corresponding to
pointing out what the nine sectors are
in Sudoku so this is a sector that's a
sector this middle one which is
completely blank right now is a sector
etc so each sector has all the numbers
you can grow the size of the puzzle it
gets more difficult you could add more
constraints as I mentioned diagonal
Sudoku might say something like both of
the diagonals the large diagonals the
full-sized diagonals I have all nine
numbers on them etc so that makes the
puzzle different you may have a solution
to the nine by nine original Sudoku
puzzle but it may not be a solution to
the diagonal a puzzle obviously the
other way round works because the raggle
puzzle only has more constraints and so
what we do here is try and use
implications right so we have these
rules and that will first forget about
computer programs and try and solve this
by the way people do then they just have
the paper and pencil and and they have a
puzzle in front of them and they try and
use these rules to discover empty
positions and
it's kind of hard to do anything with
this sector here I'm you could use the
row and column constraints obviously
even for this sector because you have
makan strains on these three based on
the fact that you have nine and seven
and one and six on this row etc but
usually you go with sectors that have a
few numbers in them you go with rows
that have a few numbers in them and you
go with columns that have a few numbers
in them and then you can try and shrink
the possibilities right so I just
because I don't want to go overboard
with respect to looking all over the
puzzle let's focus in on on eight the
number eight and one of you tell me if I
can imply something based on the
locations of eight on the top third of
this puzzle right yeah go ahead top
middle square what's your name
kai so Kai says top middle square should
be an eight right here right at the top
okay yeah that clearly can be an eight
because this is an eight here but good
so so this this the claim as this is an
eight and kai how did you figure that
out it can't be here because of this
eight it can be here because of this
eight and you need to have an eight in
here somewhere
because it doesn't exist in this sector
so that would imply that I need to put
an eight up here okay so this is what's
called a horizontal scan right the only
thing that Qaeda here was scanned
horizontally and you can imagine that so
you do not a chi did not use in order to
imply the eight and so this word
implication imply is something that
we're going to use in a more technical
sense but as well when we write our code
but an implication essentially says
these rules imply the location of the
eight right and a we didn't do a
vertical scan we did not use the fact
that in
particular implication we did not use
the fact that a column that needs to
have all numbers on it and therefore all
of the numbers on a column have to be
unique all right take a look at take a
look at this part here and let's look at
let's look at one and try and use a more
sophisticated form of implication
corresponding to both horizontal and
vertical scans to to imply the position
of a one somewhere on the puzzle right
can someone do that yeah back there okay
so the one can't be here the one can't
be here right and the one can't be here
so it has to be over here right what's
in it George
so George says the one has to be here
and he used both vertical scanning as
well as horizontal scanning in order to
imply the one so it's a little more
sophisticated okay
on top of that obviously sectors are
going to give you some implications as
well right and there's no end to this
honestly there's combinations there's
also a little bit of look ahead where
the hardest puzzles are the ones where
you run out of the eights and the ones
in terms of the examples that we have
here where we've just sort of implied
without guessing
we've implied the location of a number
and then because of that our puzzle got
smaller in the sense that there's fewer
blank locations blank squares and then
that helps us move forward right so the
easy puzzles are the ones where fairly
straightforward implications like the
ones we did here always exist are easy
to find you sometimes you have to search
a little bit look at the top look at the
power bottom look at the middle and and
then you fill things in and because you
filled things in something else now is
in play right it becomes viable in terms
of implication the fact that I put an
aid in
there I imply that the aid is now taken
you know its location and so now
obviously there's only four left here
and the fact that it's an eight here
implies that all of these can't have an
eight in the these seven locations
underneath can't have an eight in in
them right because of their constraints
so I'm this shrinking of possibilities
it's something that a human does and you
can kind of go through this process it's
an iterative iterative process that you
that you go through and you get stuck
then you can't do an implication that
gives you a number and some of the
harder puzzles you have to you have a
couple of choices and only one of them
is going to be a correct one going
forward but you don't know that at the
moment at that moment so you don't have
to can't guess and perhaps you put in an
eight over here or Nate over there and
then you say I'm gonna go with an eight
over here and then you go a little bit
further and then you realize wait a
minute you know there's no way I can
solve this puzzle because I need to put
two sevens into the sector and then you
go back and there's actually a bit of
backtracking that happens at the wrong
guess and you need to go backwards and
it's very hard to do for us it's very
hard to do for us with pencil and paper
keeping things in our head or you know
writing down notes on the side of the
paper whereas it's very easy to do that
for a computer program right and we kind
of did that already in the in the eight
Queens but we're gonna do that in a much
more systematic way over here right so
you kind of way these two ways of
approaching this problem one of which is
I'm just going to blast through the
different combinations having a giant
tree structure in my head where you know
this this might imply that particular
grid location a grid IJ equals 8
this might imply that grid IJ equals 7
and you know there's obviously a huge
number of combinations corresponding to
which of these squares that I pick and
what value I assign to those squares and
then once I do that there's another set
and this
clothes on you very quickly and so if
you just did this in a completely
brutish way there's no way your program
would ever end even on a simple puzzle
but thanks to these rules it turns out a
fairly straightforward program that's 20
lines of code is going to solve most
problems at least the ones that I've
looked at in in a reasonable amount of
time and and then you know it's just
interesting from an algorithmic
standpoint and a and an efficiency
standpoint to look and see how we can
take that fairly naive approach which
does have some pruning but it's it's
exhaustive and improve that all right so
that's kind of where we're headed make
sense
any any questions about what we have so
far all right so what we're going to do
is go ahead and and and look at at code
for Sudoku that it's of all you need to
think about now for the next few minutes
because we're going to move into
exhaustive search mode and code things
up in a computer is just those rules so
you don't have to really think about
horizontal scans and implications or
vertical scans you know that's going to
come a little bit later and we're going
to bury that up as well but we're going
to do kind of what we did for the
n-queens problem which is set up
recursive search that is going to
explore all of these different
possibilities and the equivalent of no
conflicts for for the a queen so the N
Queens problem which said there's no
conflicts here I because none of the
Queen's attack each other we're going to
have something that essentially says
this is valid so far none of the rules
of Sudoku corresponding to these three
rules that I have up on the board are
going to be violated all right so let's
take a look and so this structure
hopefully given that we've done a n
Queens I should be a little bit easier
to understand so um
when we did eight Queens or in Queens we
decided to start column by column and we
could have done row by row but we
decided to start column by column and it
was a fairly straightforward puzzle
there's obviously no real change in an
eight Queens puzzle I mean you're
solving the same puzzle as I am but if I
give you a pseudo puzzle there's more
variety to it in the sense that
depending on what I fill up the hard
puzzles are the ones that are kind of
intermediate in the sense of they're not
obviously fully filled and they're not
empty right if it's completely empty
then it's it's trivial to solve a Sudoku
puzzle you can take any solution to a
Sudoku puzzle and present it as a
solution to the empty puzzle and then if
it's if it's everything is is full
except for two things I mean it's kind
of obvious what those two things are
assuming that the puzzle had a valid
solution
so really it's it's puzzles like this
where maybe a third are full that that
that are more difficult right and it's
kind of a separate school a little
community that designs puzzles and tries
to create hard puzzles and they try and
make the humans hard
I'm sorry humans problem harder by
making this requirement of look-ahead
like I mentioned right so good so let's
take a look at the code here um so what
I want to do here and the first part
here is it is said that as I said we
went column by column in the case of n
queens and the question is where do I
start I want to do something in a fairly
naive way and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do some sort of scan you
know I'm gonna scan like that and I'm
going to find as I do the scan I'm going
to find the the next empty grid location
and I'm gonna say that is going to be
something that I'm going to try and fill
in okay so it's not going to be I
discovered this H in the in the it was
if you count in terms of the empty
locations if I went this way it was the
fourth empty location and decided to
fill that up but here I'm just in this
code I'm gonna try one two three four
five six seven eight nine here and the
first
a part of the code here that says what
is the name of this procedure it says
fine next cell to fill you know but it
means what it's name is find the next
cell find the next weird location to
fill and it simply goes for X and range
0 through 9 for Y and range 0 through 9
I'm assuming that since 0 is not a valid
entry here I could use 0 to signify
empty ok it's only 1 through 9 so 0 can
signify empty and this just returns x
and y corresponding to the the first
empty location so in this case it would
just return 0 0 ok and then if this were
full then it would go obviously it
exchanges and when exchanges you're
going over to the to the right and so
you would get a 1 1 0 back if this were
filled the next time around I'd get this
grid location etc right it doesn't
matter just like I could go column by
column by row by row as long as I have a
deterministic way of discovering the the
empty location and usually you want to
have it the same way of discovering the
empty location but even that is not a
requirement as long as there's an empty
location and you're fine next cell to
fill finds that empty location and
returns it to you you're good and this
the rest of our code is going to work
right but no reason to get more
complicated than what I have up there
all right so fine next cell to fill make
sense right good with that all right
and the generally with exhaustive search
I think the key procedure is always I do
you have a valid solution or not and you
may not have a complete solution think
of it as a partial configuration right
so this is a partial configuration and
that is valid it's not a complete
solution to the Sudoku puzzle it's a
partial configuration that's valid in
the sense that it satisfies all of the
constraints you know if I put another
aid in here it would not be a valid
partial configuration it would be
partial but not bad
right and I need to grow this I need to
grow this into a solution and when I say
solution I mean all the constraints have
to be satisfied right a configuration
could be invalid or valid a solution is
always valid all right that's just
terminology and so I want to be able to
to look high up and be able to truncate
the search and say you know what grid IJ
equaling eight because I put an 8 in
that sector which already had an 8 in it
is is something that should not be
explored and I don't have to worry about
any of the branches that come here
because immediately I've violated the
constraint right so in general I can
always check where their partial
configurations violate the three
constraints I have or not right and that
is what this piece of code does and it's
also straightforward it perhaps even
even more straightforward than diagonal
checking in the case of eight Queens but
all this does is use the construct that
says I'm going to look at essentially
this is something that is list
comprehensions in in Python the four
comes after this predicate here but
effectively what you're saying is for X
and range nine check that grid IX is not
equal to e okay and you're just looking
at e so it's valid grid IJ e takes the
grid which looks like this one let's say
and so it's got zeros in all of the
empty places and it's got a bunch of
nonzero entries in all of the places
that you see here and in addition you
have perhaps zero zero and let's call it
one right and so so this is I and this
is J and that is e okay
and so let me write that out here I J
and E where I is one zero I'm sorry I is
zero
J is 0 and E is 1 so that would mean
putting a putting a 1 up here and that
obviously is going to violate one of our
constraints but that's fine we gonna
check that and it's essentially doing
incremental checking just like we did so
it's not checking to see that that all
of the existing grid IJ values are
conflicting or not it's just saying I'm
having I'm gonna be writing something
into this grid into an empty location it
happens to be 0 0 having the value 1 and
I'm going to check whether the
introduction of a 1 into this square is
going to cause problems or not right
that's all it's that is doing right
incremental just like we had with with 8
Queens and that check is relatively easy
to do because I just need to go and I
look at the row corresponding to 2 I win
this case is the top row I look at the
column corresponding to J which is the
leftmost column and then I look at the
sector corresponding to 0 0 which is
this top left sector and I check to see
for each of those three things whether
there's a problem or not and the first
two well actually I have a problem with
the with the row and I would also have a
problem with the with the sector I
wouldn't have a problem with the with
the column but in one of them is bad
enough and so I'm gonna get a false back
so row ok is going to be false and so I
am going to return false out here
alright that makes sense so those are
the three things and this there's really
not that much here beyond taking those
constraints and and codifying them right
any questions yeah Fadi
all is essentially a Python built-in
function that is going to essentially
say that it's going to its it's a
conjunction that says I'm getting a
bunch of boolean s-- that correspond to
the generation of this list
comprehension where'd he not equal to
grid IX is it's going to give me true or
false and I need all of those things to
be true all right yeah even if one of
them is false the end is false in order
for the end to be true then all of them
need to be true all right so it's it's
just a convenient construct which is
applicable in a in in sort of a perfect
the perfect application is what you see
here it's not the most sophisticated of
applications but it works very well in
this case now for the sector I can't
actually do that and so it is a little
bit more work because I kind at this
this only works when I could put a list
comprehension in here like this and
generate all the boolean x' for the
sector I end up having to do something a
little bit different I mean you could do
things more convoluted than and use all
in here as well but it's not worth it
all right okay that makes sense good so
here's the the core routine that
corresponds to the search and ignored
this global variable here I'll explain
that in a minute
it's that's going to be our metric our
backtracks is going to be our metric for
computing performance and it's going to
be quite interesting it's going to
produce some interesting results for us
okay and then we run this on various
different examples and but but this this
core a procedure looks a lot like the
n-queens search in the sense that you
have a for loop and a recursive call
okay and in this case you
the the the for loop is going to be
something that ranges through the
different values that you find the
location that you want to to put
something into which is the the next
empty location in your current
configuration and then you need to go
put in one through nine in there and
it's is brutish you're going to put in
one and you're gonna check conflicts and
and then you'll put in two and you're
gonna check conflicts if you put in a
one and you don't get a conflict then
you get to recur and you now move into
something that is a another partial
configuration potentially but but but
obviously has one location filled from
the from the caller configuration and
then you go look for the next cell so
it's certainly possible that I'd go if
when I put in a 1 here that fails but if
I put in a 2 here I it's not gonna fail
2 is not gonna fail here because if I
just look at those constraints at 2 is
okay alright so I'm gonna put in a 2
here and then I'm going to recur and I'm
gonna go out here and I'll try and put
in a 1 here and a 1 is gonna fail
because of this and that a 2 is gonna
fail because of that I'm at 3 is a 3
gonna fail no not immediately so I could
put in a 3 here and then I recurred and
go to the next one and so on and so
forth right and for at each of these
things obviously I have to do a bunch of
search underneath and that you know
thank goodness for fast computers right
because that's why some in God I mean
can you imagine the amount of paper we
generate if you were doing this and
putting two and three and I want a new
sheet of paper for the four etc etc I
mean we can count the number of back
tracks that's how many sheets of paper
you'll need okay so so what you see here
I again ignore the back tracks I'll get
to that in just a second it's just a way
of counting the number of calls and this
thing here essentially says you know if
I'm going to be
turning I'm gonna if as long as I get
through and find a solution I want to
return true right so if solve Sudoku
grid IJ is true then I'm going to return
true and then I'm going to pop up all
the way into the top assuming I got I go
all the way down to the bottom and I get
to the point where I have a solution
that returns true which is a completely
full configuration that returns true
right but if not then I need to go a try
the other combinations and I'm only
going to Bob I'm only going to make that
recursive call if the if obviously IJ e
corresponding to this is is valid and
that checks the constraints and the only
other thing I have to worry about is it
is is essentially something that says
you know reset your grid location and
make sure that that you're that you're
setting it back to zero
after after you're done right and so
I've just made a choice here grid IJ
equals Z if I look at this line of code
here this is resetting the grid IJ
equals Z and saying it's empty because
if I've failed in all of these and I
haven't returned true in all of these
then obviously I want to change this and
you could argue that the next time
around if I and J are exactly the same
because I and J are set up here then I'm
going to override the e from a 1 to a 2
etc etc and so that is in fact correct
but I do need I I do need to reset this
outside of the loop if not inside of the
loop so it's not like I can get away
with this line of code I'm in general if
you ever backtrack you have to go back
and undo your decision and you have to
erase the 3 and that's essentially what
that grid IJ equaling 0 is doing right
you just need to undo that decision and
you can you can do this a few different
ways but the biggest thing to remember
when you do recursive search is to get
your your the undoing if your decision
which is what we call back
to be correct and if you ever leave a
mess then you'd have a problem that was
that's also true in the case of the N
Queens problem so I'm gonna go ahead and
and this is just a print routine so this
is not exactly the Sudoku that I have up
up there the Sudoku puzzle that I have
up there but it's kind of roughly
similar in complexity and I can go ahead
and run the pseudocode program and for
each of those different Sudoku problems
it's it's producing solve puzzles so
this is a solved puzzle you can check
this puzzle just real quick and you'll
find that that all of the constraints
are satisfied and then and I'm going to
explain backtracks in a second so true
says that there's a solution the number
of backtracks was 579 for the second
puzzle which was a little bit harder the
number of backtracks was six three six
three I'm sorry this is just scrolling
and for the fourth one it was 335
thousand and I'm sorry for the third one
and for the fourth one was 99 49 okay
these last two puzzles hard and if there
was a finished guy called or there is a
finish guy called our toe in kala who
designs puzzles and he claimed that this
hard puzzle in 2006 was the hardest
puzzle ever design in Sudoku and then in
2010 he came up with this more difficult
puzzle according to him that required a
lot of look ahead from a standpoint of
the human being like you know we went
back to what I said you-you-you can't
quite do this implication you have to
kind of make a guess and then you have
to go further and further down and that
I think the claim was that the hard
puzzle required like five levels of look
ahead and then the difficult puzzle
required six levels of look ahead and
obviously I given that look ahead this
puzzle has to have an initial
configuration that solvable so it's not
a trivial thing to create puzzles but
now people are using computer programs
and doing things like we are doing here
too
to find difficult puzzles and
interestingly enough the 2006 puzzle at
least for this naive computer program it
takes three hundred and thirty-five
thousand backtracks the one that that
was supposedly made more difficult into
2010 which which not only takes you know
about ten thousand backtracks right so
obviously there's a difference between
the way this this program behaves and
how you or I would behave or that you
would behave if you try to solve this
puzzle okay so let me just explain
backtracks and I'll stop to see if
there's any questions about the code so
when you make recursive calls and you
want to count the number of recursive
procedure calls you want to do something
inside each of the recursive procedures
and you want to sort of cumulatively or
collectively keep some information one
way of certainly doing it is to pass
arguments and then you have to return
the argument because when you pass an
argument and you you you modify it it's
it's not like that is going to be that
modification if it's not if it's just an
integer if it's not a mutable if it's
not a mutable variable it's not going to
be seen by the caller procedure and so
when you do recursion and you want to do
some counting the notion of global
variables is a convenient construct to
have okay and global variables
essentially say that there's exactly one
memory location associated with this
variable and we're going to go ahead and
anytime we are mutating this variable
and you're modifying it you're going to
see the effect of that in that memory
location okay so so what you have here
up here is I set back crack's to be zero
okay and that's my global variable the
fact that I put back crack's equals zero
here doesn't make this a global variable
just yet um the fact that I have global
backtracks inside of solve Sudoku now
says that there's a single copy of
backtracks and it doesn't matter whether
I'm you know at the top level of
recursion or the bottom level of
recursion
it's just that memory location
corresponding to the backtracks the name
backtracks that is getting incremented
and this could be you know
ten levels deep it could be 40 levels
deep given that I've called things you
know 40 levels in but it's just the one
backtracks okay so as you can see what
backtracks does is anytime you have a
valid location and you've gone ahead and
and essentially you don't you failed the
reason it's out here is salsa Doku did
not return true when salsa Roku actually
returns false is that's when you you you
you come out and you increment
backtracks okay so so it meant that you
you had to do some undoing you know when
you set grid IJ to be 0 that's when
you're undoing your your guess right so
back tracks you know makes sense from a
standpoint of I need to backtrack and go
in a different fork in the road okay and
so that's why I have back tracks plus
equals one right when I'm undoing you
know my decision that I made right so
this kind of gives you a sense for how
many wrong guesses that this program did
and as you can imagine then more the
number of wrong guesses the more the
computation and the longer it takes so
it is definitely a proxy for performance
but it's a it's a platform independent
proxy that's more algorithm related as
opposed to the speed of the computer
because if this computer were twice as
fast I mean I just see things running
faster even though the algorithm isn't
any better right that makes sense right
so it's a very simple use of global but
you don't want to use global variables
except in certain constraint settings
this is a fine use of global variables
right cool good so any questions about
this code so what I've done here is I
just have the naive code and I happen to
have different numbers of backtracks
because I have different inputs unlike
the n-queens problem which is kind of
boring in some sense because once you've
solved it there's nothing left in the
case of Sudoku I could change my input
my starting point and give you a
different different problems right and
so so the reason we had many different
kinds of backtracks
was was simply because numbers of
backtracks was because we had four
different inputs to the Sudoku puzzle
all right
so are we good here people understand
this code you're gonna have to modify it
right now not necessarily this code
depending on the exercise you do but
this is certainly something that
hopefully you feel comfortable with
potentially modifying all right so what
I'm going to do now is at first I'm
going to go ahead and show you some code
that corresponds to something that I is
the original code except that I'm gonna
add some smarts to it all right what I'm
going to do is at any given point of
time I'm gonna try to do some
implications without actually doing any
guessing right so the way I'm going to
integrate the human approach into this
exhaustive search approach a top level
is I'm gonna take my configuration and
before I do an arbitrary guess before I
call find next cell or maybe I have a
particular location here that I'm
eventually going to guess so I do know
that but before that I'm going to try
and see whether the current grid values
imply anything or not by using the rules
in exactly the same way or roughly I
should say the same way that we did
right when we began the lecture all
right so if we're going to try and use
some implications and maybe imply the
eight or imply something different
associated with some other location
right so this is not a backtrack right
in the sense that this is going to be I
can take this to the bank assuming I
haven't done any guessing up until this
point and assuming that the initial
configuration that was given to me
corresponds to a valid solution right
but I'm actually going to do this at
different points in the search so it
might be that I'm just gonna arbitrarily
choose a two here okay and and so I go
through and I and and and I'm gonna uh
take this in for argument's sake and I'm
gonna put up two down and then I have
not the initial puzzle that was given to
me but something that I've kind of
hacked in the center of stuck a two in
there and that may not correspond to the
solution because I just sort of put the
two down there but now given the two I'm
try and do some implications okay and
I'm gonna try and see whether there
there's things that are valid or not the
important thing is that because I put a
two down in an arbitrary way without
using implications the two could have
been incorrect I mean that's exactly why
we have all of these back tracks correct
because I've put down incorrect guesses
and then I've had to backtrack so once I
put a two down and then I fill in a
bunch of things with implications you
know I may even put an ad up there I may
put a six out here etc etc and I go deep
in and then I realized oh you know that
too was a mistake okay the two should
really should have been in there okay
now I have to clean up everything I have
to clean up all of the guesses that came
after - and all of the implications that
came after - all right that's the
biggest thing that I wanted you to take
away from this integration of
implications with the exhaustive search
it's clean up your mess clean up your
bad guesses your the fact that you say
oh but the implication was was something
that was deterministic it was exactly
following these rules
nananana yeah it was deterministic all
of that is true but you made a wrong
guess and therefore everything that you
did from then on out is is in question
and if you in fact find a contradiction
you got to go all the way back and clean
up everything and then go back and erase
everything that you had and then go take
this too and maybe turn it into a three
or what have you
all right so um before I show you the
code that does the implications and you
can kind of imagine that there's many
ways of you could do implications we did
that manually I want to show you this
part looks exactly the same as before
no change fine next cell - grid is
exactly the same it's valid is exactly
the same right um there's a large make
implications procedure and an undo
implications that I'll get to in a
second but this part here looks almost
exactly the same except that I've
replaced grid I J equals E with make
implications okay
and this is something that not only is
what is what make implications is going
to do is it's going to set whatever I
had up here it's going to set to up here
and on top of that it's going to go use
these things to go fill in a bunch of
different values in here right so it's
one extra step this is the integration
that I talked about so the idea is that
now you could do this for the original
the original as well but the point is
once you've made a guess you always want
to check to see whether that guess does
certain implications or not right I mean
that's the whole purpose of this
exercise even humans do this in the very
difficult puzzles they make a guess and
then they see whether there's some
implication or not and and maybe there's
a contradiction and they have to go back
and and undo all of that damage they
caused and change the guess okay but in
general when you have a configuration
and you add to it it's possible
certainly that there will be other
things that are employed by the the one
change that you made to it all right so
grid IJ equals E in the original code
got replaced with this procedure that
we'll talk about which I don't want to
spend a whole lot of time on but it's
it's essentially something in terms of
details but it's essentially something
that puts in different values in the
different locations and grid IJ equals
zero is replaced by undoing plication
which is cleaning up all of the
incorrect guesses and incorrect
implications and the reason the
implications are incorrect because it
came from an incorrect guess okay and so
so that's it undue implications is
trivial it just sets all of the
implications and I'll tell you what the
data structure is in a second but think
of it as as making everything zero going
back to a clean slate right I mean clean
slate in the sense that Minette
implications and guesses are cleaned up
all right so that's all there is over
here make implications is you can do
anything you want you can do you know
vertical scans you can do horizontal
scans you can there's if you go look at
the pseudocode literature and you look
in ways of playing Sudoku this books
written on how you can become a better
pseudo ku puzzle solver and there's it
you could take that and you could code
that in and you could replace make
implications with those fancy techniques
that are up there right but we've
established I'm lazy and so I only write
I only write a certain amount of code
and then I get tired and so I wrote
about 20 lines of code corresponding to
a fairly straightforward implication
just to give you a sense of of how this
would work but the most important thing
in here is not the details of making
plication and I'll give you some sense
of that before we're done but it's
really this structure that is that that
is the most important the fact that I've
done make lubrications here and undo
implications here it's the correctness a
requirement that is important to
exhaustive search okay so if I do this
and and I do kind of the implications
that we had right at the beginning of
lecture and I go ahead and run it just
take a look I won't write this out but
remember what the back tracks are for
these things roughly speaking for the
original Sudoku I'm sorry
I need to go to the shell and it was it
was 335 what is it the 579 6-3 6-3
335 thousand and nine 949 okay so if I
go off and I I run Sudoku optimized
which is doing these implications like I
described and and I go ahead and run
that the first one goes from 579 233
backtracks okay so so that's pretty good
it because it's done a bunch of
implications it's still it's it's not
super smart I mean that is a simple
enough puzzle that a human being would
not backtrack I mean a human being would
not backtrack in that first puzzle right
and you should you should check check
that and oh this thing finished in the
middle so it went to 33 only had three
of them what do I have here instead I'll
go opt
oh I see I only ran oh wow
okay so I ran into hard and difficult so
it really went from 6-3 6-3 to 33 it
went from 335 thousand to 24,000 and
then it went to 720 from 1949 to 726 I
mean the details aren't the numbers
aren't super important don't hang your
hat on them obviously if I change the
code those numbers change but you can
see that there's substantial gains to be
had
in terms of implications not making
these dumb guesses that clearly are
incorrect and that you you can fill in
if you take away some of these empty
squares then the depth of the recursion
that you have to go through become
substantially smaller and that's why
your your backtracking is is simpler so
I want to leave you with a couple of
things I want to give you some sense for
what particular implication that a
strategy that we used and so I'll just
put up make implications and give you
some sense for how this works so the
basic idea is that what I'm doing here
is I'm looking at a particular sector
and and I've created a data structure
that says the missing elements here if I
put a two in here let's just say I go
ahead and put a two in here the missing
elements here are our the set is three
four five six seven and nine all right
so this could be three four five six
seven eight nine this could be three
four five six seven eight nine and this
is quite dumb right now but each of
these different squares could be three
four five six seven eight nine okay
possibly all right and then I say so
that's the first part of the code and
then I say I'm gonna attach essentially
a copy of this set to each of the
missing squares and then I'm going to go
through and find the missing elements so
so this thing here can be a nine because
I see a nine here it can be a three
right
so I can take this thing here and I'd
take away that at the nine and then take
away the three and and I can do the same
thing with that obviously I can also
take away the the eight isn't there but
I could take away the seven and I could
take away the three the six and the one
so I go ahead and I take away the six
and the three was already take taken out
and I keep doing this and I try and
shrink the possibilities corresponding
to this particular square the curtain
that has the set of different
possibilities and if I ever so when can
I make an implication what is the
condition that is going to let me make
an implication when I take this set of
numbers and I start shrinking them down
using these rules that I have over on
the the right hand side there what what
is an implication what does that
correspond to in relation to the size in
relation to the set right yeah behind
you right that's exactly right
if you have one element in this set then
that's an implication if I have two
elements in the set it's not implication
because I don't quite know what you do
there but if I had one element in the
set that's an implication and that's it
that said you know this code is not
complicated check if the V set is a
single turn which is a single element
and I'm going to go ahead and append to
this implication which is a very
straightforward data structure that says
this is the grid location I grid
location J and this is the value that
was implied by that all right so not
only do I have I J E which is the which
is the original guess that I have I also
have you know kind of a bunch of other
tuples corresponding to different
coordinates
you know k ik l coordinates and the
value call it V associated with that and
these are all the different implications
that I can collect together in this list
and I can just add those things in to
make implications and then I keep going
and then if I ever realize I've made a
bad guess I have to undo everything by
zeroing them all out which is making
them all empty all right so one thing
that this code does and you can you can
take a look at it and I would encourage
you to do the first exercise which is
taking these implications and making
them a little more powerful by adding
like three or four lines occurred to
this
this code and exactly what you have to
do in this exercise and I'll show you
what the results should be in in just a
minute but let me just spend 30 seconds
explaining to you how you could do a
little bit better than what this code
does so what I've described to you
really is this get this set you know
imply get a single term etc and then you
can do this obviously for each of these
sectors and that's what this does you
had a for loop up there that does it for
each of the sectors right grab a sector
and go ahead and do an implication for
that sector now this code just runs
through the sectors you know 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 and then discovers the
implications if they exist adds them to
the apply list and then throws up his
hands and says I'm tired I'm done I
don't want to do any more ok what could
you do that's an improvement
given what we have described and what
I've told you so far what is an
incremental improvement over going over
these sectors once and doing these
implications and storing them and moving
on what was an incremental improvement
exactly you don't have to stop right
there's no reason to stop if you're
implying right once you put something in
here and you've gone through 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 got the implications you can put
them into the grid and then start over
again 1 2 3 4 that's what humans do
right when humans put something in and
they don't stop they just keep going
until they get to the end right now
first all of these implications are
could be incorrect if that first guess
was incorrect there's no there's no
change there but there's nothing that's
stopping you from from turning this this
little thing there's a loop here that
simply corresponds to making a pass over
the sector's but you can put this whole
thing into a loop and and you keep going
through the loop until you've you
basically have no change that happens in
your in your grid ok so that's four
lines of code and I'm not going to show
you what those four lines of code look
like so close your eyes in case it's a
and this is the solution to that code
and I'm going to go ahead and run it and
you saw what those numbers where with
with respect to do the back tracks but
if you do this extra implications the 33
went down to two okay for that example
so this is not optimal because I wanted
one right so if I wanted to be a human
being that took this easy puzzle and
just sort of went all the way without
making any incorrect guesses I would be
doing implications and that would go all
the way and I got close with with two
and I didn't print out the intermediate
ones but the 24,000 went down to 11,000
and I forget what the last one was it
went down right so with four lines of
code and with the optimized code that
I'll put up you should be able to get
those numbers in your in your first
exercise or you could solve diagonal
Sudoku or even Sudoku or you could spend
the rest of the day coding whatever you
want whatever all right see you next
time
you